I do this podcast called unqualified and
it's a relationship podcast and we give
people relationship advice attempt to
because I'm really bad at it cuz I don't
know what I'm doing and I wish you'd
swear because I would emphasize that
more but yes maybe the dogsville
is there anyone know that you feel like
on your because people was asking me now
that I'm a show is it anybody anyway I'm
dying to have on is there anyone you're
dying to have on your podcast little Kim
look him I love you right now that's
awesome
like most people would be like you guys
can feel it well okay the first the
first red carpet I walked it was for the
MTV Movie Awards and little Kim was
right behind me and she was just wearing
what do they call those things yeah yeah
thanks tease somebody knew that right
away she's got some on right now it's
already that's how we roll oh yes you
know I'm not gonna lie if I worked hard
for that body
oh you can't eat the flowers of course I
love it get it don't don't say you got
another flag on the play coming bro
you're gonna vomit you shouldn't eat
that so see you'd love to have her on
your show yes yeah she'd be interesting
should be a cool guest I mean if we get
her because it'll be with your help I
will we are sending out a pigeon right
now Lil Kim you know getting qualified I
did it's amazing I'll do it with you
yeah there you go yeah pasties are no we
will accept you any I didn't pasties
anything you want to wear everyone is
welcome
that was long tattoo you need to calm
down man I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this